the challenge and they provided
leadership
in fact the g20 has proven a strong
pillar
and a key partner for the european union
helping us to keep
international cooperation running
some of the main areas we've been
working on
in the g20 context are health
the economy climate change and
better environmental protection to
prevent
future disasters and in all these four
areas europe has recently made decisive
contributions alongside the g20
and has driven the agenda forward on the
global stage
so let me refer to these topics first of
all
of course global health and the
coronavirus pandemic
this pandemic has caused an
unprecedented shock
to the entire world in terms of lives
lost
livelihoods affected and of course
economic
costs naturally our top priority is
to stop the virus not only in europe but
in the world
and for this we need to continue
investing to make sure that vaccines
and therapeutics can be mass produced
and can be
distributed globally at affordable
prices
we have been instrumental in helping set
up
the act accelerator and its covax
facility
these are our main tools to achieve the
wide distribution now as of
november 2nd 94
high-income countries have confirmed
their participation in kovacs
and 92 low and middle-income countries
the objective is to purchase 2 billion
doses
by the end of 2021 for the low and
middle income
countries pledges
of 1.8 billion dollars have recently
been made
for procuring vaccine through covax for
the low and middle income countries
more will be needed in 2021
for vaccine procurement so the estimates
are
around 5 billion us dollars
and funding is also needed for
testing and treatment in the act
accelerator
the total needs were estimated at 38
billion dollars
of which four billion dollars have been
made available so far
the funding needs for the act
accelerator
seems to be very big very large but they
are small in comparison with the cost
of this pandemic and this is why
i have written to the g20 together with
erna zolbach
cyril ramaphosa and dr tedoz
to ask for support to mobilize
the funds needed let me
stress another point in the context of
the pandemic
the world needs to be better prepared to
protect humanity against
future pandemics we have to learn our
lessons
and of course we will need to work
together beyond
the current coronavirus pandemic
the world health organization should
play a leading role in this field
and yes it needs to draw
the lessons from the current pandemic
and improve its overall effectiveness
in fact all countries need to better
work together for improving
global health security that's a new
topic
and to support these efforts the
european union
will co-host next year a global health
summit with the italian g20 presidency
that's
that's the point where it has to be
discussed
and while the united states has resisted
engaging on this topic so far
i'm very hopeful now with the new
president-elect that this will change
indeed the next administration
has already committed to increase
multilateral cooperation
including in the health field
the second big topic of course of the
g20 is
the economy and since the beginning of
this crisis
europe has lived up to the phrase we
will do whatever it takes
to support our economy and yes
other g20 members have also adopted bold
economic measures to minimize the
economic and social damage
from the pandemic tomorrow
i will stress the importance of
maintaining economic support measures
until the recovery is firmly underway
i will also stress that our collective
recovery
must be sustainable and it must be
inclusive
it must be in line with the 2030 agenda
and its sustainable development goals as
our compass
here the european union will lead by
example
by focusing on the twin green and
digital
agenda you know our priorities
and we're aiming to achieve climate
neutrality by 2050
we will also continue to promote
an inclusive and equal recovery
based on robust social protection
systems
on decent work for everyone and on women
and youth empowerment
and we will emphasize the need to
continue supporting the most vulnerable
in particular africa
in this context i very much welcome
the g20 depth service suspension and
effort initiative
that provides debt relief to the poorest
countries
and its extension for another six months
this brings me to the third big point
that is climate change
last year at g20 the us broke the
consensus
in view of the opposition to the paris
agreement
this year i'm happy to see that u.s
are supporting the conclusions
at the summit i will once again
urge g 20 partners to commit to the full
and effective implementation of the
paris agreement
we've made progress the european union
is already walking the talk
as you know we started the european
green deal a year ago when we committed
to reach climate neutrality by 2050
and as you know that we have proposed to
reduce
eu greenhouse gas emissions by at least
55 percent
by 2030. following our lead
by now half of the g20 members
such as japan china south korea or south
africa
are already committed to achieving
climate or at least carbon neutrality by
2050
or soon after this is a big step forward
effectively addressing climate change
will require
a decoupling of economic growth from the
exploitation
of limited natural resources cup 26 in
glasgow in november
2021 will be an important moment
to consolidate the world's ambitions in
this respect
we also expect of course new momentum
from the new
u.s administration on this issue thanks
to
the president-elect's declaration that
the u.s would join
the paris agreement once again
alongside fighting climate change
we need to focus global efforts on
protecting our nature and addressing the
alarming loss of biodiversity
we see around the world this is
as important for our nature as it is
for our health and our economies we all
know that the increasing pressure on our
nature and wildlife
is a major factor behind the rise of
zoonotic
diseases and it is a fertile breeding
grounds
for future pandemics
this is why we need an ambitious global
agreement
at the next u.n biodiversity conference
in kunming and china next year
this cup 15 for nature must basically be
like the cup 21 was for climate
and we need a peristyle agreement to go
with it
a recent biodiversity strategy calls for
protection of at least 30 percent
on both the eu's land and
sea areas by 2030
but we need the same ambition
at the global level if we are to protect
humanity against this global threat
voila as you can see tomorrow's g20
summit
is the occasion to mark a new beginning
in multilateral cooperation
to address global challenges we all face
and with our partners we stand ready to
be a real driver of this new beginning
thank you so much
thank you very much president i now give
the floor to the president of the
european council
[Music]
european ladies and gentlemen
in many ways tomorrow's g20 summit will
be about
what a post-profit world will look like
and what we want it to look like
we will discuss how to make that future
more resilient
more sustainable and more inclusive and
i will share a few concrete ideas
in these three areas first resilience
kovit 19 has come as a surprise to many
of us
but it's not the first bubble pandemic
and sadly
it won't be the last one so
how can we prepare for future pandemics
an international treaty on pandemics
could help
prevent future pandemics and help us
respond
more quickly and in a more coordinated
manner
it should be negotiated with all nations
and u.n organizations and agencies
in particular the who the who
must remain the cornerstone of double
coordination
against health emergencies a treaty and
pandemics
could complement its efforts second
this weekend's discussions with also
center on
how we can build a more sustainable
future
our focus this year is clearly on
fighting the pandemic
but the threat of climate change is no
less urgent today than yesterday
so i will say a few words about how our
climate goals
are linked to our trade and finance
policies
first on trade we firmly support
open trade and we need to reform wto to
make
our international trade policies greener
and we are working on making respect for
the paris agreement
an essential part on all future
comprehensive
trade agreements and as you know we have
decided
to make europe the first climate neutral
continent
by 2050. we will not accept
that substandard roots unfairly compete
with european products and
damage the planet we are looking into
establishing a carbon border
adjustment mechanism to avoid carbon
leakage
this mechanism would of course be in
line with wto
rules climate change is a global
challenge
we therefore need to create a green
global level playing field
second the dream transition is a huge
opportunity
to drive forward our economies and to
make this happen
we need massive investments the private
sector
will be key to these investments there
are
no double standards for so-called green
bonds for example
and this in my opinion a missing link
and an
area where we can make progress we need
to develop common standards for these
green bonds
that mobilize saving for green
investments
the european union has started work on
this
and we believe the g20 should urgently
address the global issue of green
finance
finally how can we make our post of it
world
more inclusive profit 19
has hit the most fragile hardest
and g20 finance ministers have done
good work the g20 depth moratorium
is a good step in the right direction
and it might have to be extended beyond
mid 2021 but in our opinion
it's not enough we are convinced that
the more
that we live is needed all creditors
need to do their share no country
must be perceived as getting a free
right
multilateralism means everyone on board
we need a new model of sustainable
financing for development particularly
in africa to break the cycle of
over indebtedness my name
[Music]
i would ask you please to switch on your
camera
and to specify to whom you are
addressing
your question and we start with
anz antigua you have the floor
question to both of the leaders there's
great concern that there will be not
enough support from the g20 summit
for the world progress countries in the
corona crisis
so i would like to know how do you
assess the progress made so far
in the debt relief talks is there any
chance
from that you see that it will be go far
enough
thank
president yes perhaps to complement that
indeed the depth relief is an important
pillar but
also of course the access to
vaccines treatments and diagnostics in
the corona
pandemic without any question and there
the fact that we were able to first of
all create together
the act accelerator for vaccines
diagnostics and tests
the development of those but also
that we created together the covax
facility that as i said is responsible
under the supervision of gavi to
purchase
and deploy vaccines to low and
middle-income countries and they're
certainly increasing to
the african union this is an important
pillar to fight the pandemic
a precondition to pick up a gun with
economic activities and here
the pledging so far the funding in the
covex facility
is 1.8 billion
dollars of which 800 million
euro team europe so the european
commission and the 27 member states
have funded it's the largest funding in
the world for
the kovacs facility and i think this
shows a focused
uh focused focusly addressing
the need for a vaccine to fight the
pandemic besides that
of course all the investments the
economic investment for the economic
cooperation we do have
are crucial this has been detailed out
by the president of the council
thank you we now move to james franey
james you have the floor
hello yes go ahead
uh right it's working now yeah thank you
very much eric for this question
um yes uh to both presidents if i may
ireland's uh broadcaster rte
has just reported that 95 of the brexit
trade deal
has been uh completed very simply
to both presidents is that true yes or
no
and then if you could just please give
us a steer on the timeline when do you
think
this deal is going to be a hundred
percent finalized thank you
well um zero
comment on percentages because you know
that
nothing is agreed till everything is
agreed
this is the precondition but indeed
after difficult
weeks with very very slow
progress now we've seen in the last days
better progress more movement on
important files this is good
we still have of course the three main
difficult issues the governance
the fisheries and the level playing
field but within
the frame of the level playing field
progress for example
has been made on the question of state
aid
but there's still there are quite some
meters to the
to the finish line so there's still a
lot of work to do
what the timelines are concerned indeed
um
the time pressure is high without any
question
um at the moment being there
is a break because there was a coveted
19 positive case in the
negotiating team good is
that before that legal text
was on the table so there's a lot to
work on and this gives the precondition
uh to proceed for example if necessary
in vtcs because there is now substance
where you can go through line by line
word by word
to work on that the whole team is
engaged and working
tirelessly day and night to indeed reach
the natural deadline we have to be done
by the end of the year
i don't know if the president of the
european council wants to add anything
no i have nothing to add and i i fully
share
the answer expressed by ursula very good
thank you
then we move over to david hashenhorn
thank you eric for for both presidents
uh
thanks there's there's some concern that
because of the pandemic
this has been a bit of a lost year
otherwise in global diplomacy
because the sherpas the ministers
couldn't travel i wonder if you could
talk about are there goals that you
would have liked to see
achieved by this g20 chaired by saudi
arabia
and also if you could just address
there's there's also the the matter of
not being in riyadh as
uh had been planned that perhaps the
kingdom of saudi arabia is
avoiding some questions and concerns
about human rights that would have been
raised i wonder if you're communicating
those in some other fashion to your
virtual hosts
this is certain that uh that indeed
we have adapted our way of working
because uh
you you observe that uh we used a lot
and it will continue to use a lot of
virtual meetings it's not exactly the
same because uh
at the diplomatic level it's also useful
to have some meetings in person
in order to try to create more more
confidence uh
more trust in order to to negotiate it's
also
easier to have meetings in in person
even if the european level you have
observed that
uh during during many months it was
difficult to have
a physical meeting it's only in july
that we had
this uh meeting in order to agree on the
next
multi-annual budget and the recovery uh
fund this is my
my first point about saudi arabia this
is a multilateral meeting that we have
this sweetie but we know that at the
bilateral level we don't hesitate
uh to put very high on the agenda uh the
question of uh
the human rights the uh democratic the
democratic values and the
and the the the freedoms and uh at the
juvenile political level we have
worked uh very hard uh
with all the institutions but especially
with the high representative in order to
promote our values to defend
our interests and you know that we had
the last month's
debate uh orientation and strategic
debates at
the level of european currency in order
to try to strengthen
our our european unity on uh
important and even essential
geopolitical challenges
i can only emphasize what the president
of the council says
indeed on the bilateral side we follow
very closely
the situation of human rights in saudi
arabia
but also of the people defending
the fundamental rights including women's
rights
and individual rights so this is an
ongoing topic
and it's a very serious topic but i also
want to emphasize that
we it's important that we de-link the
multilateral and the bilateral
aspects and this multilateral forum
is has a very strict agenda it has a
very clear
protocol it's not a bilateral summit the
chair
changes every year rotates every year so
the g20 is a specific place and besides
that
we have the bilateral topics what the
topics are concerned we are discussing
in g20
it is very good that the green
topic climate change is top of the
agenda
this needs urgent attention from all of
us
and the good part is in g20 you can see
how things
changed from one year to the next and if
i look at the fact that
a year ago there were almost no
declaration
of strict goals of climate and carbon
neutrality
well this year we have more than half of
the g20
that have declared either carbon
neutrality
or climate neutrality by 2050 or shortly
after shows that there is a good
movement going on
we hope for the us to join two with very
clear and distinct goals
so this is one topic that is important
and
any g20 presidency
with this situation of course has to
deal with the topic of the pandemic as
we've
described right now thank you we have
time for one last question and it goes
to oliver grimm
oliver
do you see me i hope you hear me my
camera yes i think you see me now sorry
uh question to uh president fond du land
oliver again with the austrian newspaper
the world health organization is now
actively advising against the use of
creme de severe in the treatment of
hospitalized
patients a panel
organized by the world health
organization came to the conclusion that
it has no
effect on the treatment it doesn't
alleviate the respiratory
distress that these patients are in so
basically it doesn't work
my question to you is have you already
gotten has the commission gotten in
touch with
gilead the producer from whom you bought
doses to the tune of about i think 70
million euros
do you see a way secondly of getting at
least part of the money back
thirty what would be your advice to
member states now should they continue
using
rendezvous or not and thirdly in light
of this
is there any sort of insurance clause
in the um in the deals you now signed
with
vaccine producers that in the case of uh
of a check in the case of these vaccines
are working
you might get some of the money back
thank you
so first of all um i will not get into
a scientific analysis
of randy severe this is for science to
do that
i think this is important to look into
the data to look
into the reasoning of the
but this is for our scientists to do
that and then to draw the necessary
conclusions on it
what the vaccines are concerned one of
the
main negotiating point in the contracts
for the vaccines is of course
liability so they have to be effective
and they have to be
safe the way we approach
the building the portfolio for the
european
union is that the commission
provides advanced purchase agreements
with investment in the build-up of
capacities
to produce masses of this vaccine
in case that it is a successful vaccine
so it is a bad indeed in this case on
six to seven
different vaccines so far we've gone
well with that later on
if a vaccine is a success
proves efficient then the member states
are able to
buy the pre-reserved doses this is the
stepwise approach we have in this field
so in other words the the broad
portfolio shows that
there are two points that are important
make sure that you don't miss
any technology that is produced on the
european market
and make sure that the capacities for
production are built up widely
as we need a lot of vaccination for the
450 million people
in the european union and of course our
neighborhood too
thank you very much with that we
conclude today's press conference
thank you for your attention
[Music]
you